et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Louis bourlange bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
députés modem des Hauts-de-Seine et vous
présidez la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'Assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice le
groupe Evra bonjour Fabrice
bonjour bonjour Jean-Luc bourlange vous
revenez tout juste d'Ukraine vous étiez
pendant plusieurs jours vous êtes rendu
notamment avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a une brune
pivée qu'est-ce que vous retenez de ce
voyage écoutez nous retenons d'avoir
cette toujours très impressionnant c'est
c'est très dépaysant d'aller en Ukraine
parce que ces moyens de transport assez
assez particulier cette longue nuit en
train et on arrive dans un pays qui est
totalement en guerre totalement mobilisé
très accueillant très très accueillant à
ceux de ses amis comme nous qui et qui
ont eu leur apporter la solidarité et
nous avons donc rencontré
sommes allés une partie de la délégation
étalée sur les sur les lieux de des
atrocités et nous avons tous rencontré
les très hauts les plus hauts
responsables à commencer par le
président Hélène ski et il rencontre
avec le président de ski c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant
parce que c'est un c'est un personnage
qui il est plus fascinant encore en
relation directe à la télévision parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui s'adresse à vous
qui vous parle qui vous avez vous avez
immédiatement un rapport avec lui il est
plein de charme plein d'intelligence
d'une très grande vivacité d'une très
grande mobilité et ceux qui
caractérisent fondamentalement sa
démarche c'est une absolue détermination
et les messages que nous avons reçus
étaient des messages
ultra déterminés je ne négocierai pas
avec Poutine si je suis prêt à négocier
avec les Russes mais il faut qu'il
change de gouvernement donc ça
a pas de raison de dire ça pour vous je
ne sais pas si la raison en tout cas il
est évident que Poutine les discours et
les actions de bottines depuis plusieurs
mois on discrédité comme interlocuteur
en même temps si on attend un changement
hypothétique sur lequel personne n'a
prise en Russie ça veut dire qu'on
négociera pas avant très longtemps mais
en même temps on ne voit pas sur quoi
négocier parce que Poutine a organisé
des référendum dans des conditions mais
non seulement illégales mais totalement
aberrante dans les oblastes qu'il a
rattaché à la Fédération de Russie les
résultats ne signifie rien il a
construit sur ce référendum une espèce
cérémonie nationaliste invraisemblable
on a d'ailleurs vu que maintenant il
était plus question de nazis plus
question d'aide humanitaire au peuple
craignant qui s'agissait simplement de
reconstituer la Grande Russie c'était
une cérémonie entièrement nationaliste
donc c'est évidemment inacceptable très
virulent contre l'Occident pardon aussi
ça comment il faut l'interpréter mais
écoutez je crois que c'est très
compliqué d'interpréter le discours de
Vladimir Poutine cette assurément un
discours très violent très très dur avec
la rhétorique habituelle de Poutine
vous savez c'est comme les ce que disent
les enfants c'est celui qui dit qu'il
est
c'est à dire qu'il accuse l'Occident de
tout ce qu'il devrait selon qu'il
devrait s'accuser lui-même l'agressivité
la volonté de détruire le fin du fin
c'est c'est la cupidité la prédation
quand on voit la fortune qu'il a
constitué à la personnelle à la tête de
la Russie on se dit quand il dénonce sa
cupidité nous avons affaire un
spécialiste bon donc tout ça est une
sorte de construction en miroir de
lui-même c'est extrêmement traditionnel
l'agresseur s'opposant en victime mais
derrière ça il me semble que
de la manifestation de Moscou était
tournée vers le peuple russe en lui
disant voilà nous avons les premiers
avantages de ce qui n'est pas une guerre
mais ce qui est quasiment une guerre
avec les quatre les quatre régions qui
sont rattachées donc nos enfants ne sont
pas morts pour rien et du coup ça peut
être pour lui la base d'une d'un accord
d'un entrée en négociation en disant on
va maintenant je garde la Crimée je
prends les pays et on peut causer et
évidemment cette proposition est
inacceptable par
l'Ukraine mais ça c'est le problème
c'est que l'idée de Poutine est sans
doute de diviser la communauté
internationale de dire un certain nombre
de pays où plus fragile comme le nôtre
d'ailleurs avec des gens qui sont assez
proûtiniens dans une partie de la
population de dire voilà il faut arrêter
les frais on va partager etc et
fragile dans cette histoire
on a quand même
un parti le rassemblement national qui a
été directement branché sur monsieur
Poutine et le LFI également même si au
sein de les filles on voit bien que les
éléments sont partagés mais le l'idée
notamment de ne pas aider ce qui est la
pire des hypocrisies de ne pas aider les
Ukrainiens on est solidaire des
Ukrainiens mais on leur envoie pas
d'armes militaire
on d'accord vous on vous on vous aime
mais on vous laisse on vous laisse
crever la bouche ouverte bon ça ça va
pas vous estimez que du côté de Marine
Le Pen comme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon les
choses ne sont pas claires aujourd'hui
les gars donc je crois qu'elles n'ont
jamais été claire ni du côté d'Éric
Zemmour mais non il n'y a pas eu le
quartier toute l'idée que développe par
exemple le RN c'est dire il faut pas
faire de sanctions c'est
maintenant les sanctions pédales or il
est absolument clair que les sanctions
les sanctions sur le sur le le gaz et
sur le pétrole non pas bien fonctionné
en termes de prix
au bout des sanctions
mais les Russes sont certainement
arriver assez loin dans la privation on
dit qu'aujourd'hui ils sont ils en sont
à détacher les les puces et existants
sur les sur le matériel les armées âgées
pour les affecter à des à des
équipements militaires il y a donc une
une extrême essoufflement de l'économie
russe la technologie russe qui est la
conséquence de de des sanctions
par intérim du rassemblement national il
dit les sanctions sur les
semi-conducteurs ça marche les sanctions
contre les oligarques ça marche mais les
sanctions sur l'énergie sur le gaz
notamment ce sont les Français qui ont
payé
ça veut dire que replie couteau j'ai pas
écouté les garçons j'en donne par-delà
il faut se méfier de ce que de commenter
les choses qu'on a pas vraiment lu même
si je suis tout à fait confiant dans la
sincérité et la la véracité de votre
interprétation mais je crois qu'en tout
cas ce serait une évolution parce que
moi ce que j'ai entendu jusqu'à présent
de la part de Madame Le Pen et c'était
une condamnation nette et sans bavure
des sanctions il faut d'autres sanctions
sur l'énergie donc il faut continuer il
faut certainement
je vais vous dire l'essentiel selon moi
c'est effectivement de continuer à fixer
la haute technologie russe et c'est
surtout de de d'alimenter l'Ukraine en
armement en munitions en moyen de
frapper à long terme l'Ukraine a
bénéficié l'Ukraine a réussi pour trois
raisons la première c'est la
détermination morale et la bonne
organisation très décentralisée
d'ailleurs de ces troupes ça en a vu on
a vu ça vraiment le système c'est un
système qui fonctionne la base
deuxièmement un armement continu qui
avec des armes très bonnes le César
français les grands canaux américains à
très longues distances etc et il faut
assurer la continuité le
rat du visage allemand en munition et
troisièmement une innovation stratégique
de première grandeur qui est ce que les
militaires appellent la transparence de
la transparence du champ de bataille
c'est-à-dire que les Russes peuvent pas
faire un mètre un mouvement d'un mètre
sans que les systèmes d'information
occidentaux les repères sache où ils
sont les informations sont communiquées
à qui de droit et les riposes sont donc
à la fois
livraisons d'arbres qu'est-ce qui vous
dit vous dit c'est suffisant
on n'est pas rentré dans une négociation
c'est plus loin il nous a dit son
extrême gratitude il a pas pas du tout
marqué l'idée qu'on n'en faisait pas
assez etc on a du mal parce qu'on a du
mal parce que notre armée a été très
sacrifiée il y a que depuis cinq ans ça
il faut rendre hommage à un président
Macron sur ce plan c'est que la loi de
programmation militaire a été respectée
dans ces objectifs c'est nouveau le
général De Villiers a quitté le
tamajor dans les conditions que l'on
sait mais sont testament a été si je
puis dire assumé par le Président de la
République mais il faut continuer
d'autre part nous sommes constamment
exposés sur d'autres théâtres nous avons
été au cours des 30 dernières années
exposées en usa vie exposé en
Afghanistan exposé en Afrique pour en
revenir à Vladimir Poutine
la question du nucléaire il prend dit la
menace
elle était implicite bien sûr il faut la
prendre au sérieux écoutez je crois que
c'est c'est une affaire compliquée ça je
pense d'abord que les Russes ont moyen
de faire de destruction dans notre vie
quotidienne ce qui se passe en Baltique
est un avant-goût de ce qu'ils peuvent
faire sans utiliser l'arme nucléaire
deuxièmement l'arme nucléaire ça sert
absolument à rien pour eux ça
provoquerait un effet de sidération
massif c'est quelque chose qui les
mettrai complètement aux bandes des
nations de notamment des nations de
sabarquant si je puis dire la Chine là
le Brésil l'Afrique etc et donc pour
pour la Russie ce serait une calamité
donc c'est pas dit ça c'est totalement
irrationnel maintenant est-ce que
Poutine est un individu rationnel est-ce
que les hommes politiques qui sont
parvenus à ce degré de paranoïa et à ce
degré de concentration de pouvoir sont
toujours rationnelles on a des exemples
historiques qui montrent leurs endotés
vous en doutez parce que six Poutine
était totalement acculées par exemple
si si la conjovensive
ukrainienne
allait aller réussir totalement pense
qu'il est loin d'être le cas parce que
l'équipe des forces n'est pas aussi
aussi atteint qu'on le dit ici ou là
d'une réaction de désespoir mais je
crois que la solution c'est pour ça
qu'on va s'empêcher de résister et de
défendre le colis Ukrainiens vont pas
défendre leur territoire la solution là
c'est à tout à fait raison la solution
c'est que les Russes changent de de
dirigeants c'est arrivé un an après Cuba
les Russes ce sont les Soviétiques ce
sont débarrassés kruchev c'est ça ça
existe les changements de alors les
modalités de l'alternance dans un pays
comme la Russie sont assez compliqués à
imaginer mais enfin là il y a un
problème et moi je trouve que le
discours de Monsieur Poutine
paradoxalement
que tout le monde a ressenti moi aussi
comme un discours extrêmement violent
contre l'Occident était un discours qui
n'était pas dénué d'une certaine volonté
de solutions rationnelle assez à
vous avez senti une ouverture
non parce que l'idée qu'on va quand même
prendre la moitié de ou le cas ou le du
territoire ukrainien on peut pas
construire que c'est une ouverture mais
j'ai je pense qu'il a essayé qu'il
essaie de trouver une une voix pour se
sortir lui-même de l'impasse dans
laquelle il s'est mise donc je crois que
c'était plutôt un discours qui était
comment ça peut être quoi cette voix
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est de dire voilà on arrête les frais
on garde les quatre provinces on garde
la Crimée et vous encaissez ça et si
vous n'encez pas ça vous aurez froid
que la solution aussi elle ne peut pas
venir de la Chine est-ce que à l'heure
actuelle ils se sont pas les Chinois qui
détiennent éventuellement la clé de la
fente c'est la même idée c'est la même
idée c'est il a évidemment il a très
bien compris je pense l'avertissement de
sa marque et de il a très bien compris
que les Chinois trouvaient que ça
commençait à bien faire que les Indiens
également ils ont beau trouver un peu
davantage dans les commerces
énergétiques que les Africains les
Africains voudraient que ça s'arrête
aussi et donc s'il veut et les Turcs
s'il veut puisque c'est un débat entre
l'Ouest l'est et le reste et l'arbitrage
du reste est en train d'échapper pendant
longtemps l'arbitrage du reste a été
plutôt contre l'Ouest puis avec les
développements des derniers mois et
notamment les offensives réussie des
Ukrainiens l'arbitrage du reste est
plutôt contre Poutine et ça il en est
très très inquiet je reviens sur ce que
vous disiez sur les armes parce que
c'est intéressant ce que vous me disais
tout à l'heure sur les armes et sur la
livraison les livraisons d'armes qu'on
fait à l'Ukraine vous rappeliez que la
France est aussi engagée sur d'autres
terrains de guerre ça veut dire que
jusqu'à quand l'armée française pourra
continuer à livrer des armes à l'Ukraine
est-ce que ça met l'armée en péril ça
l'armée au péril vous savez les
problèmes les problèmes des militaires
c'est que ils ont des armements ils
aiment bien les garder pour pouvoir s'en
servir plus tard il y a toujours un
moment il faut s'en servir c'est quand
même le grand conflit que nous avons
simplement nous abordons un débat
budgétaire dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles comme vous le
savez et là moi je suis de ceux qui
disent qu'il ne faut pas me lire sur les
dépenses militaires il ne faut pas me
lire sur l'exigence de de renforcement
de nos moyens le budget est un budget
d'augmentation des forces armées et je
crois qu'il faut soutenir cette
augmentation c'est pourquoi par ailleurs
je trouve qu'il faut faire des réformes
structurelles même s'il faut les faire
selon des modalités
acceptables comme par exemple les
réformes sur l'agir traite je crois que
nous avons on va venir mais ça veut dire
qu'on a encore les moyens de livrer des
armatiques pendant plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois on a toujours les
moyens de faire les choses à condition
qu'on se représente la gravité de la
situation ce qui est impossible et ça le
président l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
c'est de faire comme si rien n'était
changé pour les Françaises pour les
français ce qui se passe depuis le
février est un défi géopolitique un défi
à leur existence à l'existence de leur
valeur à la sécurité et il faut se
mobiliser et se mobiliser ça ne demande
pas de notre part des sacrifices énormes
certainement pas comparable au sacrifice
immense que qu'on sent le peuple
craignant mais ça demande des efforts
des adaptations et on sent pas tout à
fait toujours ce besoin très partagé
dans l'ensemble de l'opinion au dernier
mot là-dessus puisque le débat aura lieu
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est un débat qui
sera aussi très politique qu'est-ce que
vous attendez vous de ce débat ecoutez
le gouvernement veut nous dire
le gouvernement a demandé ce débat nous
sommes extrêmement prêts moi j'y
participerai en tant que président de ma
commission mais j'attends effectivement
et j'attends que le gouvernement marque
une détermination sans faille aux côtés
de l'Ukraine sa volonté de maintenir les
aides en armement et sa volonté de
préciser
la nature et le volume des sanctions
puisque le président a appelé un nouveau
tournevis en matière de sanction je
crois qu'il faut effectivement faire le
point sur l'efficacité des sanctions et
sur les orientations que doivent prendre
ces sanctions à l'avenir donc il faut
rester fidèle à nos engagements
maintenir notre détermination et
préciser techniquement la nature de nos
interventions dans les semaines qui
vient du rassemblement national et de la
France insoumise vous attendez aussi des
choses c'est leur affaire moi il est
rare que je sois d'accord avec eux mais
je les écoute toujours alors on va
parler d'un autre sujet on va parler
pose la question de la réforme des
retraites justement puisque vous en
parliez oui François Bayeux votre ami a
donné un coup de frein au bulldozer
Emmanuel Macron il y a quelques jours
l'invitant à prendre le temps de la
discussion de la réformer les retraites
en France est-ce qu'il est allé trop
loin
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un danger que
rien se fasse oui il y a toujours un
danger que rien ne se fasse puisque rien
ne se fait en matière des retraites
depuis 5 ans et que toute économiste
sérieux est tout budgétaire sérieux
c'est que c'est la variable essentielle
sur lequel nous pouvons effectivement
agir au service de l'économie et au
service de des comptes publics français
donc il faut faire les la réforme des
retraites je ne crois pas que que
François Bayrou est proposé de différer
sur le long terme cette réforme ce qu'il
a dit et je crois que c'est très partagé
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
qui est de la formation principale de la
majorité qui n'est pas au MoDem a dit la
même chose
on prête à la première ministre d'avoir
soutenu des idées comparables auprès du
président de la République
on dit le fait de passer par amendement
dans le cas de la loi pfss face à ne ça
ne l'a fait pas comme disait ses enfants
ça ne marche pas
avec ça je suis je suis d'accord à la
condition que moi je suis très
réformateur je suis
mais je mesure
l'immensité des forces styles je suis et
ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup pour le pays
quand on voit il y a Monsieur Martinez
mais il y a Monsieur berger qui vient
encore de la CFDT qui vient encore de
prendre des positions très rigoureuses
contre une mesure d'âge dans les mesures
d'âge s'impose elles sont
croyez qu'en politique quoi que ce soit
règle tout et on peut s'arrêter de faire
de la politique ça c'est pas vrai on
mais on peut on doit effectivement
améliorer la situation Emmanuel Macron
et là on va avoir il y a quand même et
c'est ça que François Bayrou a fait
pareil comme d'autres il y a des
réactions immenses et il faut il faut
s'y prendre intelligemment je crois que
ça demande quand même une négociation on
va gagner beaucoup d'argent le système
va gagner beaucoup d'argent si on
allonge la durée de cotisation et si on
prolonge l'âge
légal de passage à la retraite il faut
qu'une partie de cet argent limité
servent à gérer la pénibilité à gérer
l'adaptation c'est ça la question du
travail du des sexagés tout le monde a
des positions assez arrêtée sur ce sujet
il y a ceux qui veulent réformer et qui
disent qu'il faut absolument avoir une
mesure de report de l'âge légal de
départ sinon ça ne sera pas une réforme
suffisamment courageuse et les syndicats
qui disent nous on en veut pas bon
est-ce que cette concertation de trois
mois ça va vraiment changer quelque
chose
c'est une question centrale la question
que vous posez je n'ai pas la réponse
mais je vais vous parler très
franchement j'ai été très inquiet tout
au long de la campagne électorale que ce
soit la campagne présidentielle ou la
campagne législative je n'ai pas senti
nulle part ni dans la majorité ni dans
l'opposition des projets qui étaient
adaptés à la réalité à long terme de la
situation la campagne qu'on a faite a
été tournée sur les trois mois Emmanuel
Macron a fait campagne sur un
allongement de la durée de travail et
qu'il estime avoir été élu sur ce projet
et qu'il a possibilité de réformer sur
ce projet je crois qu'il faut c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles je l'ai
soutenu sans aucune arrière pensée
j'avais bien d'autres raisons de le
soutenir parce que les options
fondamentales qui sont les siennes ce
sont les mêmes que les miennes mais sur
ce point précis il a il a pris un
engagement qui a un petit peu varié dans
ces modalités en cours de campagne et je
je crois qu'il faut s'y tenir non mais
ce que vous nous dites si je comprends
bien Jean-Luc mélench c'est que personne
y compris Emmanuel Macron n'a fait
campagne sur une vision long terme sur
un cap pour la France je vous dis la
même la même chose que que ce que je dis
sur l'Ukraine je trouve que dans ces
profondeurs l'opinion française n'est
pas adapté n'est pas pris pleinement
conscience des enjeux géopolitiques
économiques et sociaux dans lequel est
plongé la France et elle n'a pas pris
pleinement conscience de ce que ça
implique dans les dix années qui
viennent les politiques en ont pris
pleinement conscience est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron on a pris pleinement
c'est très frappant ça le Emmanuel
Macron
a certainement pris conscience de cela
d'où cette impression que nous avons
tous un petit peu étrange c'est-à-dire
que on le sent on le sent inquiet on le
sent inquiet par le décalage entre ce
qu'il sent nécessaire et qu'il dit
quand il donne des faits des tiens des
propos assez généraux mais des propos de
de réalisme de d'appels à l'effort etc
et des réticences du pays je crois que
nous vivons ce moment particulier qui
est un moment grave parce que si nous
échons si effectivement les Français
disent tous ces efforts iNous ils nous
cassent les pieds Macron nous casse les
pieds les hommes politiques et femmes
politiques nous cassent les pieds ça
finira par
l'arrivée au pouvoir non pas d'ailleurs
selon moi de l'extrême gauche je pense
que les filles jouent le rôle de comme
on dit d'idiot utile dans cette affaire
c'est-à-dire qu'ils font l'agitation
mais ça risque de finir par un pouvoir
d'extrême droite qui personnellement
préoccupe beaucoup donc ça veut dire que
Marine Le Pen pourrait succéder Emmanuel
Macron pour vous si Emmanuel Macron rate
son quinquennat c'est ce qui peut se
passer
une inquiétude que partage François
Bayrou
nous nous avons le et c'est apparemment
ce que partage aussi le le président de
la République puisqu'on dit partout que
il voudrait pas se retrouver dans la
situation d'anobama qui je verrai
remplacer par notre homme et un scénario
à l'italienne un scénario oui enfin
c'est un on a quand même un pouvoir très
à droite en Royaume-Uni de depuis
Johnson on a un pouvoir très à droite
maintenant en Italie on a un pouvoir
très à droite en Pologne on a un pouvoir
très à droite en Hongrie on a un pouvoir
assez à droite en Autriche à tout ça et
me montre que il y a une vraie dérive
vers la droite de la droite à laquelle
nous devons
faire attention parce que ça ne
correspond pas aux options ni à nos
valeurs ni à l'intérêt fondamental des
peuples européens qui doivent s'unir
s'ils veulent gagner dernière question
très rapidement
le gouvernement n'exclut pas de revenir
sur le nom cumul des mandats encore
quelqu'un qui est là vous en pensez quoi
je pense que on prend pas des réformes
on fait pas des réformes par petit bout
comme ça le cumul des mandats ou non
cumule des mandats ça dépend l'idée
qu'on se fait du Parlement c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le Parlement est faible
et les parlementaires n'ont pas accès
aux responsabilités locales donc les
parlementaires c'est un peu le couteau
sur l'âme au calmement que le manche en
mettant bon mais moi je suis plutôt
partisan de renforcer le pouvoir du
Parlement donc de faire la
proportionnelle pour que le pouvoir du
Parlement soit véritablement différent
organisé différemment du pouvoir
présidentiel et qui puisse peser
pleinement
c'est pas le retour des députés maires
ou sénateurs
des députés de mer et laisser à travers
c'est le retour de du président roi
merci Jean-Luc vallonge merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre entreprise ce matin et
le débat sera donc à suivre va partir de
16h débat sur la guerre en Ukraine dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
merci Fabrice on passe au club des
territoires
[Musique]